mr hahn of the european council appointed member of the european commission after the
approval ratings of the european
parliament
i undertake to act in full independence in the general interest of the union
because in the fulfillment of my
duties i respect the treaties and the charter
of fundamental rights of the european union
in the performance of
my duties seek nor take instructions from any
government, body, agency
or any other body
abstain from any action inconsistent with
my office or the performance of its
duties
I accept the provisions of the Treaty on the
Functioning of the European Union
stated commitment of
member states to know that they will respect this
independence and not
seek to influence commissioners in the performance of their duties
i also
undertake during and after the performance of their
duties  to fulfill the duties arising from my office
,
in particular the duty to be honorable and restrained in accepting
certain duties or benefits
after the end of that duty
[applause]
there